on a assez peu de contrôle sur le temps
qui passe
les jours se succèdent les minutes les
heures les années et puis on a
l'impression qu'on peut rien y faire
vraiment on voudrait trouver une façon
pour que les deux journées durent
toujours une façon pour kelly tisot
toujours pour que notre jeunesse
toujours que l'emphase de nos enfants
tôt pour toujours mais le parent
continue à nous glisser entre les doigts
eu l'impression qu'on peut absolument
rien fait pour l'arrêter ni même pour le
ralentir mais je pense personnellement
qu'on se trompe là dessus en fait je
pense en tout cas qui est parfaitement
légitime de se poser la question est ce
que l'été pourrait ne jamais finir
la cigale ayant chanté tout l'été se
trouva fort dépourvu lorsque la bise fut
venue
pas un seul petit morceau de mouches ou
de vermisseau elle a crié famine chez la
fourmi sa voisine la priant de lui
prêter quelques grains pour subsister
jusqu'à la saison nouvelle
je vous père et lui
vous venez d'entendre un extrait de 20
secondes d'une fable de la fontaine des
connus suivi de 20 secondes de silence
vous serez peut-être d'accord avec moi
pour dire que ces deux tranches de 20
secondes n'avait en fait pas du tout la
même durée aussi vous allez accepter ma
métaphore ma métaphore qu'elle n'avait
pas du tout le même poids pendant la
fable en votre esprit était complètement
consacré à suivre suivi l'histoire si
vous en rappelez vous que vous en
rappelez ou pas si vous la connaissiez
ou non ce qui est plutôt plutôt rare
bref vous étiez actifs d'une façon ou
d'une autre tandis que pendant les 20
secondes de silence et bien vous
attendez que je dise quelque chose que
le plafond ne tombe sur la tête
bref vous vivez un moment assez
particulier dans un tel talent que vous
le silence est pas exactement la chose
qui dominent habituellement dans des
noms des durées si courte
bref vous étiez d'une certaine façon
passif et là où je veux en venir c'est
que c'est ce qui vraiment c'est ce qui
se passe dans notre esprit qui détermine
notre perception de la vitesse
d'écoulement du temps mais je suis
évidemment ici pour vous parler de
musique on dit en général que la musique
c'est l'art des sons c'est la première
page du solfège de vincent d'indy pour
ceux qui sont moins qui ont fait ça pour
moi la musique c'est aussi peut-être
surtout un art du tas composé s'est
découpée du temps et puis le remplir
c'est faire des tranches de temps et
puis habiter cette france là les colorer
on a vu avec les petites expériences
autour de la fontaine qu'est ce qu'on
met dans les tranches de temps savait
qu'on les habite va drastiquement
influencer sur notre perception de la
vitesse d'écoulement du temps et sait et
c'est exactement ce genre d'illusions de
perturbations tabourel que la musique
et particulièrement apte à créer voici
un moulin et des vaches mais un petit
village à l'horizon vous voyez et voici
une des chansons préférées de ma fille
simone qui a eu deux ans hier marie en
120 au moulin mari un sans faute au
moulin
c'est pour y faire moudre son grain
c'est pour y faire moudre son grain à
cheval sur son âne ma petite mam'zelle
maria
à cheval sur son âme cattin ça n'allait
tour
alors vous avez entendu la chanson qui
ralentissent pas ce qu il fait toujours
beau courir ma fille tandis que notre
chronomètre à l'écran lui et grenay
cécile ses seconds avec la régularité
habituel de la machine finalement
c'était donc deux temporalités
superposer deux temporalités en conflit
ans qui vont saintais qui vont se
interagir une lune avec l'aude qui vont
faire en sorte qui est extrêmement
difficile de garder une perception
objective de ses deux temporalités l'a
d'ailleurs certains d'entre vous ont
peut-être eu l'impression que c'est
l'horloge qui accélérait alors qu'en
fait c'est clairement moi qui
ralentissait la musique peut créer ce
genre d'illusions perturbations temporel
de toutes sortes de façons
et c'est d'ailleurs de nous taquineries
qu'on fait avec les mélomanes ou les
compositeurs c'est de jouer avec cette
perception du talent on peut imaginer y
musée qui nous projet créé des attentes
donc il nous projette constamment dans
le futur on peut au contraire imaginer
une musique qui fait constamment appel à
la mémoire et qui donc nous projette
constamment dans le passé je les dis
écrire la musique composée s'est
découpée du temps il remplit arrive
demain et c'est curieux parce que vivre
au fond c'est ça aussi c'est découper du
temps faire des trans et puis le remplir
si on peut donc arriver à donner
l'illusion que le temps ralentit en
musique nécessairement on peut faire la
même chose avec notre vie non puisqu'ils
s'y employer les mêmes techniques et
donc donner une direction
c'est à dire un sens aux événements que
ce soit des événements musicaux ou les
événements de notre vie créer un
équilibre entre les attentes comblé et
les attentes déçues créer un équilibre
entre l'action et la contemplation entre
l'ancien et le nouveau entre la
répétition et la surprise un peu petit
catéchisme du conte du compositeur mais
qui sont aussi d'excellentes règle de
vie peut-être le sens les lieux de
l'enfance l'enfance des lieux c'est une
pièce pour orchestre qui m'a été
commandé
dernière pendant que symphonique de
laval et la ville de laval à l'occasion
du 50e anniversaire de la ville
c'est un peu pour ça que je suis ici
avec vous et alors que symphonique de
laval n'a donné la permission gentiment
nous faire entendre un petit extrait
c'est une oeuvre dans laquelle j'utilise
toutes sortes de techniques pour
perturber le temps changement de tempo
changement de dimension ralentissement
accélération alors en guise de
conclusion je vous faire attendre ce
petit extrait et y'a rien à voir
alors vous pouvez tout simplement fermer
les yeux et moi je vais disparaître
merci
à
oh
on va